this is a production of Cornell
University
thank you Charlie uh you have to excuse
me I'm used to talking a lot with my
hands uh so I'll try to hold this close
but um yeah so I'm uh in the employee
degree program and so I also at
Moonlight as a squash breeder and
what's up
oh sorry
I'm in charge of the breeding program a
lot I managed to Reading Program along
with Michael
and most people know we do all kinds of
concur bits lately the cucurbance all
from all over the world beans peas and
peppers but uh today I'm here to tell
you about the novel resistance Gene that
we found in cucumber to moshada
um resistance against powdery mildew and
our search for markers in the genome so
uh yep squash and pumpkins cucurative
species this time of year we all have
the uh in our bellies we have our
pumpkin pie uh we have jack-o-lanterns
on our doorsteps rotting away three main
species is
your your smaller Jack O'Lanterns and
acorn squash uh yellow squash
um spaghetti squash many others gourds
they could cover the Maxima which has
our kombucha squashes a buttercup squash
and the giant pumpkins oh you probably
saw giant pumpkins in the news recently
uh they broke another world record for
their size and the seeds are going for a
thousand dollars a piece so I'll make
sure to save your uh giant pumpkin seeds
um and then finally
finally as long as they don't have PVP
right so
um so and then finally we have a
cucumber to moshada which is we're here
to talk about today and we have our
um Butternut type squash uh tropical
pumpkins kalabatha and also um so a
processing pumpkin fields pumpkin
Dickinson which is actually if you buy
pumpkin pie filling in a can it
primarily comes from this species
and it's a giant watermelon shaped uh
pumpkin
um but so for powdery mildew resistance
between all the three species the
there's currently a single source of
powdery mildew resistance that Henry
Munger enter grass from cucurberta
martinisii or in the 70s and he brought
it over into cubita moshada and that
seems to be a dominant source of
resistance uh a chromosome 10. our novel
source of powdery mildew resistance uh
uh does not have that uh Gene so uh so
we wanted to go about finding out why as
we know single Gene resistances are
fragile so we're uh happy to soon be
able to offer this uh Pottery
multi-resistance in a commercially
viable line so we set out to identify
the inheritance and segregation ratios
for this novel powdery mildew resistance
uh Regina type resistant acceptable bugs
from the F2 population from our we did
actually a greenhouse green and a
generator where very quickly and very
soon going to generate Marker set and
identify candidate genes and created
some back cross populations this summer
so that we can
verify the markers and uh hopefully in
the next four to five years we hope to
have some
um some commercial cultivars that we can
offer with this uh powdery mildew
resistance
and so uh in order to do a screen for
powdery mildew with the F2 population I
um collected powdery mildew spores from
the fields and I inoculated a flat of a
susceptible uh susceptible plants and I
found this key for powdery mildew types
and it looked to me to be most likely uh
Canadia formed in Chains like a
potosphera this is a photo I took using
a microscope with a camera I also looked
at it with a better microscope and so it
seems to me to be potospherazanthi which
is not a surprise it's the most common
uh Pottery will do in the world uh air
Stefani chicory Sierra is the other
common powdery Mill to fix cucurbits but
I did not see it on there those other
spikes or trichomes on the leaf
uh so here's the setup of our Greenhouse
Green we typically had 10 plants and a
15 cell flat uh with forage pots
um either we had 10 plants or the F2 uh
10 plants and one of the controls
parental controls f1s versus f1s and
this is a lot doesn't look like a lot
but this is a lot of plants this is
close to like 500 plants me and Michael
spent many days uh evaluating all these
plants so it was during covert so we had
to wear masks and it wasn't wasn't a
whole lot of fun but we got it done and
I think uh the data will show we have
some high quality data and of course we
had a bugle in the greenhouse so we
could compare it to um
uh the commercial current commercial
source of powdery mildew resistance
that was produced by its lab so here's
some images of the plants to get an idea
of what to expect in the F2 we looked at
all the controls and we evaluated them
on the leaf surface the underside of the
leaf the petioles and the stem and what
you can see here is Waltham the
susceptible control has uh mildew all
over the lease service on the underside
of the leaf the patios the stems bugles
the novels the sorry bugle the
commercial source of pattern or mildew
resistance
um has mildew a little bit of mildew on
the on the leaf surface but not really
any mildew on the stems or petioles on
the underside of the leaf
um so we look at our novel source of
powdery mildew resistance it's hard to
find powdery mildew anywhere there's a
little bit of spoilation but very low
and it does get a little bit of necrosis
but uh it keeps growing and does very
well and if we look at both the f1s
between our novel Pottery mildew
resistance and well done we see uh
mildew all over the stems all over the
Leafs
um so it doesn't appear to be a very
dominant uh that's right
and then looking at it 20 days later we
see about the same thing uh as I just
described uh both the f1s are about
dying from powdery mildew and as is
welcome bugles is surviving it do okay
but it does have mildew on the leaf
surface and our but our novel Pottery
mildew resistance Source uh looks pretty
clean and good the leaves do finesse and
get a little cruises but whatever the
action of this powdery mildew resistance
is it seems to prevent any sporulations
and and the difference between bugle and
the novel Pottery military resistance
seems to be uh Leaf surface formulation
so then when we look at the data from
from me and Michael looking at these
hundreds of plants
um again yeah
stem had very little mildew on either
the resistance sources but there's
plenty of mildew susceptible in both the
f1s the patio is about the same seems to
be a little
something going on there with the f1s
get a little maybe a little qualitative
quantitative resistance but um and again
I'll leave four
on the bottom is about the same uh both
the resistance sources very low
um this is acceptable and f1s uh have
about 25 Leaf coverage but and then it
again when we look at the top of leaf
four for this resistance Source
um it is where it stands out from bugle
to the novel uh our novel powdery mildew
resistor stands out against bugle with
the pmo gene and so that's where we see
the difference so when
uh we wanted to think about the F2
population and what we should use to
score as resistance susceptible uh this
is a
a graph of the F2 scores of the whole F2
population and the leaf scores and so we
decided to draw this Red Line in the
Sand about where the
um at the upper bounds of the standard
deviation for uh the novel resistance
Source kind of saying this is about
where we see a lot of change and when we
ran our chi-square test for three to one
ratio I got a p-value of 0.427 which
looks very probable that this has at
least a single major Gene controlling
the resistance
uh and uh looks like a recessive
resistance perhaps there's some
quantitative aspects and some modifiers
but it looks pretty strongly to be a
recessive resistance or a dominant
susceptibility
um so you say Greg that was a great
Greenhouse Green but what about in the
field well this is what I saw in
September this year throughout all the
controls uh Waltham and the two f1s had
very little leaf left after the powdery
mildew
um and bugle had you know quite a bit of
leads more than Baltimore the two F ones
between our novel powdery mildew
resistance but our novel Pottery will do
resistance has this is full foliage and
yes it does produce fruit and they don't
taste too bad but they're not a type of
uh squash that many people would
recognize in this country so we're
looking forward to uh introgress into
some more common types
so for genotyping going back to the
Greenhouse Green we extracted DNA from
the 22 resistant and 22 susceptible F2
plants
and the parents we did next week 500 550
sequencing we got about 40x coverage on
the parents and Forex coverage on the
individuals in the books and
um so
uh then I ran uh the reads through a
qtl seek by all kind of package and yeah
output of the VCF file which would then
further annotated by snip bath packets
and
um
and then it takes the VC annotated VCF
file which also has a a Delta Delta snip
index on there so we got a a significant
hit on chromosome 13. and when it got
over the 99 percent uh confidence
interval there's a couple other places
where it got close to the 95 confidence
interval but uh it definitely looks like
uh it never breached to 95 so uh looking
at chromosome 13 I divided up the region
into about a hundred thousand base fare
chunks to try and find map to region and
I sent away for some primers to uh for
developing markers and hopefully the
primer should be in our mailbox right
now and so we're going to take Remnant
DNA from the resistant individuals and
hopefully this week run some PCR on
those to try to find out which markers
are most closely correlated with this
resistance trait and then fairly uh this
summer we'll test the markers on the
back cross population that I developed
this summer and uh soon we'll also
verify in a different population and
hopefully in three uh four to five years
we should be able to have a resistant
cultivar to release to The Growers and
seed companies so we're excited to be
able to offer
Growers and other source of powdery
mildew resistance and cucumber to
moshada that will help reduce fungicide
use and hopefully uh
um so the development of powdery or
fungicide resistant powdery mildew
strengths
thank you very much for your attention
and
thank you to my committee Michael and
Anna Rock Agarwal and jack for Rizzo for
helping me with the uh with the genetics
genomics and everybody in madlab helped
plant the seeds Courtney I think did the
seeds for the uh Greenhouse Green and
our Harvest fruits and all that so
thank you very much
any questions
yes do you have any plans to stack the
two genes do you need benefits from a
stock oh yeah we that's something we
want to try very soon and so we'll see
what happens and hopefully as I said
yeah the bugle genes on that came from
cucumber to martiniza is a chromosome 10
so hopefully they have a benefit there
is there tends to be a little bit of a
trade-off with the powdery mildew
resistine so we'll have to
uh and years was a lot of pottery mildew
um they tend to do better
than the susceptible cultivars so we'll
see if there's a benefit to having it
stacked or not
um great presentation
um I was just wondering if you know
anything about if there's any braces for
powdery mildew and like is there a
potential for like major heat resistance
for pottery mildew to overcome it
yeah it definitely is and that's why uh
I think there are as many races I think
I have a I have to look at it again
Henry mugger and Molly John did a lot of
work on that I haven't reviewed the
literature in a while but I'll have to
take a look into that but um yeah it's
definitely potential
yes uh I suppose you've tried or you
evaluated phones they were single
crosses between the susceptible
people using the reciprocal pair of
crosses yeah so so that's what we had
there when I had the two f1s I had both
my question is if there is any effect
reporter that you found that is
dependent on the which part is used as a
female or as a part of something it
didn't seem like there was much of an
effect either way I think uh if I look
at my data is like the scores are a
little flip-flopped on one or the other
like sometimes one did a little bit
better on other parts of the like the
patio or the September there wasn't much
uh difference and leave
I think either time they didn't have a
statistical difference between either of
the f1s
for any of the locations yes the cup of
stuff they cheat them and couldn't be uh
I mean decrease the signature
the infection right
sorry could you repeat I missed the
beginning part
oh the copper sulfate yeah
the question is uh
any differences
of the foreign
the copper sulfate uh we're not sure but
that would be something definitely an
interesting question to explore
okay
thank you very much
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at cornell.edu